how much has Hollywood changed the last
40 years it's Insanity what's going on
in there look my agent called me in
about it was about 10 11 years ago my
agent manager together they're never in
the same place because they're on
different sides of the Hill there in in
California and
I felt like it was an intervention by
walking and said we can't work here
anymore because I started getting pretty
vocal on you know on the internet and my
wife says they're going to come after
you I said why what am I I'm just saying
the truth this is the truth but
apparently the truth is a horrible thing
to say on the internet as you know so
um they they said we can't work it
anymore in Hollywood you know Studios
saying no no he's a Christian he's a
conservative we can't work with him and
I thought wow this is incredible you
guys for decades are the one screaming
for tolerance screaming for freedom of
speech but as you know that's all a
one-way street with Hollywood and that's
too bad because I don't Harbor that kind
of hate and anger that they have towards
people like me I just don't I have
friends that are liberal friends that
are atheists and we get along we have a
beer we play golf we give each other a
hard time but we're still friends but
it's a different world right now in
terms of
as you know the divisiveness that's gone
on and I think it's been created a lot
by some of the presidents we've had in
the past and also certainly the
mainstream media that jump on this
bandwagon to go after anybody has a
different point of view Kevin in in
Hollywood uh Malik if you can bring me
up about five points in Hollywood if you
look at uh uh some of the guys that are
able to coexist with all the other
liberals that are in there say
politically we know which side Hollywood
leans on it's not a new thing everyone
knows about it but you see some of these
guys that are still able to keep
producing and they're almost like a
Untouchable Community they I call it the
saint status where a Clint Eastwood you
can't touch him he's Untouchable yeah
Mark Wahlberg was on Fox news last week
talking about he's moving his family to
Nevada because he wants a better
environment for his kids he doesn't want
the Hollywood thing to be there he kind
of feels like it's a better place for
him to raise his kids there are certain
guys in Hollywood that are still
producing still making some of them
obviously got blacklisted Vince Vaughn
used to do a lot of work you got a
little bit benched for a couple years
sure then he came back maybe not at the
levels he was pre-run Paul libertarian
all that stuff that he was doing how do
some of the guys that are still
conservative people know they're
concerned conservative what makes them
get away with it in Hollywood I think
like you bring up a Clint Eastwood I
think the fact that he has been such a
big star for so many years in the A-list
world I think that he uh they they know
they got a hit with him they may
disagree with them I mean was he 92
years old are you still heard he wants
to Direct One More movie I've known
Clint we're not buddies but I've known
them for over 25 years and I keep saying
Clint one line that's all I want in one
of your movies I just want to say I was
in the Clint Eastwood movie but at
Wahlberg I think Wahlberg's served in
that same category in the younger
generation but these guys there's no
fear with it you know I wasn't I wasn't
in the A-list world but I was staying
busy I mean after Hercules I did a show
called Andromeda for five years and Ron
berries has been up and um you know I I
stayed working but I do a lot of
independent movies Hollywood gave me the
boot but I still have the the industry
I'm still staying alive I shot over 45
movies since Hollywood said goodbye you
know not all of them are great but a lot
of them are pretty darn good family
movies and that's what I want to keep
doing yeah so I'm fortunate to keep my
career going but it's not like they they
can still do these big hundreds why do
you think they can do it why do you
think a uh uh for example uh Wahlberg I
want to say he's a Catholic right when
he wrote the movie uh Stu what's the
movie called father Stewart something I
watch yeah by the way it's not a crazy
movies I thought it was going to be a
better movie I'm a big
Wahlberg fan sure I wouldn't say it's
his top 10 movie of all time but it
really impacted him in a way where he
kind of came out and talked about how
this movie got me thinking family all
this other stuff how long has it been
known that Wahlberg or Clint or some of
these guys are either conservative or
not part of the camp in Hollywood how
long has that been known
um well I think it varies for each of
them I think Rick Clint it's been for a
long time I mean he wasn't afraid you
know he was the mayor of Carmel up there
and that's right just for one reason
yeah and and I just think that uh
there's there's no fear factor with them
and I think that's great I think you got
guys like Bruce Willis he's been more
vocal unfortunately he's not his
Health's not very good right now James
Woods he got banned from you know
Facebook and Twitter I got banned from
Facebook for posting a truth about covid
but uh God forbid you do that Mark
Zuckerberg's a bit of a wuss and his
trolls are the same but you know you got
I'm gonna keep fighting a good fight and
uh keep speaking for the truth and we
gotta we gotta keep doing that how these
how long have these guys done it and I I
have no idea I just know that Mark
Wahlberg I think has been more vocal
lately I think Adam Sandler's on that
side too he's not as vocal but he still
has messages in his movies that show
that he is and I know I pretty knows
he's more conservative than people
probably know but um you know it's it's
I think there's a fear factor for so
many people I get actors every time that
do my movies coming to me because I
produce my own movies I've been
directing a lot lately and they come up
hey thanks for being a voice for us I
want to be a voice for yourself why do I
have to be your voice well they don't
want the same thing to happen to them
that happened to me what year did this
this really start culminating like you
said you started acting in the 80s you
probably didn't notice it then you know
Clint Eastwood's been speaking at the
RNC for 20 years now whatever it is but
you must have noticed some sort of
slippery slope in Hollywood like was
there a trigger point when you start to
see the mechanics kind of Shifting and
and the woke isn't taking over when did
that was I've always seen it but I think
when Obama got elected I think 2008 was
a turning point
um not because he's half black by the
way he's also half white okay people
forget
um I just think that he brought forward
a different view of of America to people
uh you know he get his get his wife
saying I'm finally proud of being
American really you know because we're
not a perfect country but we're still a
country everybody wants to go to right
nobody's taking boats from Key West to
Cuba they're all coming across you
correct so
um to me it's like I I I started
noticing during those years especially I
think the last I think when Trump got
elected to get attacked every single day
here's a guy that both parties loves he
was on all the talk shows he was on the
magazines they had him on the ones he
decided to go from one side and say look
I'm be I'm conservative I'm gonna make
America a better place every day I don't
think no president has gone through what
he's gone through every single day of
his presidency and they still go after
him so but so you know what that does to
me though this gets me to think about
because at one point you're right Trump
was Untouchable Trump was Saint status
as Trump was you know Larger than Life
Tupac talks about I mean everybody would
you know rap about uh Trump and then he
goes out so so maybe the differentiator
is there's got to be a line you can't
cross with Hollywood for them to turn on
you you can be privately known as
conservative like a Mark Wahlberg or a
Clint Eastwood or Adam Sandler or some
of these names you're saying but as long
as you're not too vocal like a you know
James Woods as well as long as you're
not too local as yourself or some other
people will let you slide but you cannot
be too vocal you think that's kind of
what the line is there yeah I think for
me not being an a-lister but being an
actor that was still steadily working
and still have every years for the last
four decades
um I was easier to go after right away
because I'm not doing 300 million dollar
movies that are making a billion dollars
to the studio I mean they can claim they
can scream all they want that they love
socialism let's face it I mean Disney
still wants to make money they're a
capitalist business they can put on the
eyeglasses I don't know if jpeg wants to
make money yeah that's why you got fired
that's why I got rid of them yeah oh and
he was good at not making money yeah it
was very good not making money your
future looks bright hat click over here
and to watch the entire podcast click
here take care everybody